ce sont plus de dix mille bureaux de
vote ouvrent leurs portes à 8h les
électeurs devront donc départager
françois fillon désormais favori et
alain juppé m on le rappelle qui a
apporté son soutien à alain juppé autre
figure emblématique qui a déjà voté
c'est nicolas sarkozy
détendu au point de presque oublié sa
cotisation
de 2 euros
françois fillon et alain juppé qui ont
voté à la même heure quasiment
simultanément dans les bureaux de vote
différents évidemment vers 10 heures les
deux hommes était dans une file
d'attenté pour voter l'un dans le 7e
arrondissement de la capitale et puis
l'autre dans sa ville de bordeaux
respire une forte mobilisation parce que
j'espère tout
dépend du vésinet jusqu'au bout et ça va
marcher au futur attend le verdict des
électeurs voilà maintenant vous êtes
confiant c'est eux qui parlent pas les
candidates merci jean claude bibeau
d'aborder dans sud ouest ce matin
quelques vérités malheureusement sont
apparus trop tard lisez l'article gens
que libé dans sud ouest vous comprendrez
voilà qu'on prendrait un peu décalé
calomnie j'ai été l'objet la victime
sans que personne ne dise rien sur 2121
bureaux dépouillés et bien les scores
respectifs étaient pour françois frion
de 69,5 pour cent des voix et pour alain
juppé de 30,5 pour cent des voix la
campagne des glaces qui est celle d'un
certain nombre de réseaux sociaux ali
juppé des choses comme cela il n'a pas
accusé françois fillon de cela mais
c'est une campagne je vous laisse à vos
courses et s'installer et ça c'est
profondément malsain les écarts bouge
assez peu puisque françois fillon être
édité de 68 5% tout à l'heure c'était
69,5 donc qui baisse de 1 point c'est
une magnifique victoire de françois
fillon et pour ce qui me concerne sans
attendre je veux simplement lui dire
toutes mes félicitations lui dire que
c'était une très belle campagne que je
me place dès à présent et indépendamment
de ce qui a pu nous séparer dans le
passé à son entière disposition présente
aloi rassembler pour gagner ça va être
difficile mais en ce qui nous concerne
nous respectons l'éthique de la primaire
la règle du jeu c'est à dire d'être
rassemblés derrière celui qui gagne
comme je viens étaient engagés j'apporte
dès ce soir mon soutien à françois
fillon je lui souhaite bonne chance pour
sa prochaine campagne présidentielle
alors que la politique peut être dur
mais je veux lui dire qu'il reste
évidemment une figure de référence pour
toute notre famille politique
alain est un homme d'état et il le reste
on peut saluer aussi la dignité d'alain
juppé homme d'état qui n'a pas attendu
pour apporter son soutien à celui qui
avait gagné la primaire paris d'ailleurs
françois fillon l'a évoqué ce soir il a
parlé de plus de justice et de
solidarité voici la poignée de main
j'aurais juste ajouter une dernière
chose ce n'est pas alain juppé qui m'a
blessé ce sont les photographes il ya
quelques instants